in this video we'll go over logistic
regression this is a learning algorithm
that you use when the output labels why
is a supervised learning problem are all
either 0 or 1 so for binary
classification problems given an input
feature vector X may be corresponding to
an image that you want to recognize as
either a cat picture or not a cat
picture you want an algorithm that can
output the prediction which you only
call y hat which is your estimate of Y
more formally you want Y hat to be the
probability or the chance the Y is equal
to 1 given the input features X so in
other words if X is a picture as we saw
in the last video you want Y hat to tell
you what is the chance that this is a
cat picture so X as we said in the
previous video is a MX dimensional
vector given that the parameters of
logistic regression will be W which is
also an annexe dimensional vector
together with B which is just a real
number so giving an input X and the
parameters W and B how do we generate
the output Y hat well one thing you
could try that doesn't work would be to
have Y hat be W transpose X plus B you
know kind of a linear function of the
input X and in fact this is what you use
if you were doing linear regression but
this isn't a very good algorithm for
binary classification because you want Y
hat to be the chance that Y is equal to
1 so Y hat should really be the team 0
and 1 and it's difficult to enforce that
because W transpose X plus B can be much
bigger than 1 or can even be negative
which doesn't make sense for probability
that you want to be between 0 & 1 so in
logistic regression our output is is
there going to be Y hat equals the
sigmoid function applied to this
quantity this is what the sick one
looks like if on the horizontal axis I
plot Z then the function sigmoid of Z
look like this so it goes smoothly from
0 up to 1 let me label my axes here this
is 0 and it crosses the vertical axis at
0.5 so this is what sigmoid of z looks
like and we're going to use Z to denote
this quantity W transpose X plus B just
the formula for the sigmoid function
sigmoid of Z where Z is a real number is
1 over 1 plus P to the negative T so
notice a couple things if Z is very
large then e to the negative Z will be
close to 0 so then sigmoid of Z will be
approximately 1 over 1 plus something
very close to 0 because you know e to
negative of the very large number will
be close to 0 so this is close to 1
and indeed we if you look on the plots
on the left is Z is very large then
sigmoid of Z it is very close to 1
conversely if Z is very small or it is a
very large negative number then sigmoid
of z becomes 1 over 1 plus e to the
negative Z and this becomes needs a huge
number so this becomes you know think of
it as 1 over 1 plus a number that is
very very big and so that's close to 0
and indeed you see that as Z becomes a
very large negative number sigmoid of z
you know goes very close to 0 so when
you implement logistic regression your
job is to try to learn parameters W and
B so that Y hat becomes a good estimate
of the chance of Y being equal to 1
before moving on just another note on
the notation when we program neural
networks will usually keep the parameter
W
and pram to be separate we're here B
corresponds to and interceptor on in
some of the classes you might have seen
a notation that handles this differently
in some conventions you define an extra
feature called x0 and with that equal to
one so that now X is in R of and X plus
one and then you define Y hat to be
equal to Sigma of theta transpose X in
this alternative notational convention
you have a vector parameters theta theta
0 theta 1 theta 2 down to theta and X
and so theta 0 plays the role of D
that's just a real number and theta 1
down to theta and X play the role of W
it turns out when you implement your
neural network will be easier to just
keep B and W as separate parameters and
so in this class we will not use any of
this notational convention that I just
wrote in red if you've not seen this
notation before in other classes don't
worry about it it's just that for those
of you that have seen this notation I
wanted to mention explicitly that we're
not using that notation in this course
but if you've not seen this before is
not important and you don't need to
worry about it so you've now seen what
the logistic regression model looks like
next to train the parameters W and B you
need to define a cost function let's do
that in the next video